hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 american action and thriller movie
called honest thief
the movie begins with a man who is
drilling and breaking into a safe and
the next day it is revealed by the news
that 658 000 has been stolen and the
police have found no clues at all about
the suspect of the robbery the man on
the news calls him in and out ban it as
he has done eight robberies in the past
six years unidentified
tom carter the name of the thief later
goes to a self-storage warehouse where
he meets annie a grad student he wants
to rent a storage unit to store all the
money he stole
during their short conversation he finds
himself having a crush on her and she
seems to find him charming to
one year later tom and annie are in a
relationship
he brings her to be exact breaks in with
her to an apartment for sale and asks
her whether she wants to live together
with him
at first even though she likes the place
annie hesitates and rejects the request
as she just divorced
tom then manages to convince her and
finally she agrees to moving in together
with him
on the other side fbi agent myers goes
to the office with his lovely dog tazzy
upon arrival he tells his superior agent
baker that he is going to divorce and
his wife is letting him keep the dog
he adds that his wife chose to take
their house instead of their dog
back to the charleston hotel tom calls
the fbi revealing that he is the in and
out bandit he surprisingly wants to turn
himself in
however myers and baker don't take him
seriously since they have received a lot
of calls claiming themselves as the in
and out bandit recently he promises them
to hand over all the stolen money but
they have to ensure that he receives a
reduced sentence no more than two years
with full visitation rights in return
while asked why he wants to turn himself
in he admits that he wants to be with
annie for the rest of his life without
feeling guilty about his past
thinking that he's bullshitting baker
orders agent nivens and agent hall to
interview tom
it's been two days and the agents have
not come
so tom calls the fbi back and complains
to myers he feels insulted when being
called the in and out bandit because it
sounds unprofessional after the call
agent nivens and agent hall suddenly
show up at the hotel
to convince the agents tom reveals some
specific details of the robberies to
them
he tells them that he only focuses on
small town banks with older vaults as it
is easier to blow
a vacant building next to it is also a
must because he will use it as his
entrance through the adjoining wall
after he blows the vault and takes all
the money he covers his tracks by
patching the wall with plaster and then
painting it since the agents are
unwilling to make an agreement without
proof tom gives them the location where
he keeps the stolen money which is in
the self storage at the beginning of the
movie
they look into the storage and both of
them are surprised when hall discovers a
box full of money meaning that tom was
telling the truth
nivens becomes greedy and intense to
keep all the money by himself
at first hall disagrees as he is a good
agent and he thinks it is not the right
move
however after nivens convinces him that
this is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
and hall also realizes that he needs
extra money to support his family he
eventually reluctantly goes along with
it while moving the boxes to their car
annie confronts them as she didn't
recognize them on the security they lie
to her telling her that they are tom's
old friends while serving in the marines
they store the money in niven safe house
and then return to the tom's hotel
niven suddenly pulls out his gun and
attempts to shoot tom tom reveals that
the money they took away was just one
third of the total stolen money he
intends to tell them the location of the
remaining money but the conversation is
interrupted when baker suddenly shows up
at the hotel
for no reason nivens immediately shoots
his superior to death
tom fights the greedy agent and both of
them fall out of a window annie is
shocked when she sees them and tom tells
her to run as they get away from the
agents they then attempt to chase after
tom and annie but the couple manages to
run towards the parking building
nivens and hall go in there but cannot
find anyone
tom then steals another car there and
eventually escapes from the corrupt
agents he drives annie to safety on
their way he is forced to tell the truth
to his lover they pull over and annie is
highly disappointed with tom after
hearing the truth
he tells her about how his father was
fired from a pipe manufacturer company
and then committed suicide he reveals
that he started robbing since the ceo of
the company embezzled millions from the
employee pension fund he robbed the bank
where the ceo kept the money he admits
to annie that robin gave him life but he
decided to stop when he met her
slowly but sure penny starts to forgive
him tom then suggests annie to leave the
city because he knows that the fbi will
chase after her while tom stays and will
try his best to prove that he's innocent
at the same time myers arrives at the
hotel and is shocked when he discovers
his superior's dead body
after that he questions nivens and hall
to figure out what happened to his
partner as expected they lie telling him
that tom killed baker the next day the
agents discover that the thief was
actually a former marine where he served
as demolition expert they then decided
to go after annie to seek some
information a few moments later annie
calls tom and she informs him about
getting footage from the storage
warehouse that would be proof of the
agent stealing the money turns out that
annie is still in the city and he
immediately orders her to get on a bus
unfortunately nivens appears at the
storage warehouse's office and attacks
her she tries to fight back but nivens
is just too strong and he eventually
knocks her out he then tries to shoot
her but hall intervenes and prevents him
from doing so while secretly taking the
security footage from annie tom arrives
late and immediately takes his lover to
the hospital he is enraged and calls the
agents
nivins plays dumb and denies that he has
attacked annie as myers is listening to
the conversation
tom has had enough with them before
hanging up he vows to go after him which
makes both agents panic
a police officer comes across a van
recognizes tom and decides to chase
after him the agents are informed about
the situation and immediately join the
pursuit after he manages to dodge the
cop the agents confront him and tom
deliberately crashes his car into theirs
the car gets stuck and they engage in a
gunfight after several attempts tom
eventually manages to get away from the
agents
not long after meyer spots tom and
chases after him he briefly fights him
until tom points his gun which he stole
from hall at myers
tom tells the truth to the agent telling
him niven's killed baker and attacked
danny and meyer seems to believe him
tom returns the gun and goes away from
there that night nivens goes to the
hospital and attempts to kill annie but
he cancels his intention when he sees
myers is sitting inside annie's room the
next day myers questions the agent
regarding what tom said earlier on the
phone but nivens lies again and the
agent returns the gun to hall
later in the night tom breaks into
hall's house and gives hull a surprise
attack he regrets everything he has done
and decides to hand over the security
footage to tom
he also warns tom about niven's plan to
kill annie tom immediately rushes to the
hospital and takes her away from there
bringing her to a safe house the next
day using his knowledge for marine tom
assembles a bomb while talking to annie
after that annie insists on joining tom
as he goes after nivens they then go to
niven's house where tom secretly planted
a bomb inside there
he calls the greedy agent and warns him
about the bomb
nivens luckily still manages to get out
before the bomb explodes and runs away
with his car
on the other side myers meets annie at
the storage warehouse where she shows
the agent the rest of tom's money to
gain his trust
nivens goes to the safe house where tom
who holds hall hostage suddenly appears
nivens is furious when he discovers that
hall betrays him tom tries to break up
the fight but the cocky agent pulls out
his gun and starts shooting tom through
his partner
he manages to escape with the money and
drives away in his car luckily tom has
prepared a backup plan
he calls nivens telling him that he has
planted a bomb under the driver's seat
which is pressure sensitive and will
detonate if he moves even the slightest
movement
nivens has no choice but to pull over
and wait for the bomb squad to arrive
not long after the bomb squad arrives
and examines the bomb
he then reveals that the bomb is a dud
with nivens carrying the stolen money
myers orders his men to arrest the
corrupt agent furthermore it is revealed
that tom secretly put a phone inside
hull's pants which recorded their entire
confession earlier he then sends it to
myers who finally totally believes in
him after hearing the recording
later that night outside the fbi
headquarters annie approaches the agent
while tom suddenly calls to turn himself
in
tom subsequently shows up and myers
promises to do his best to help tom get
a lighter sentence
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching